it's one of the most exciting moments in
any tennis match the player steps up to
the baseline
maybe bounces the ball a few times and
then smashes an ace past their opponent
and while the pros make it look easy the
tennis serve is actually an incredibly
complex stroke hitting a tennis serve
effectively is one of the hardest things
in sports to do even if you somehow
master the mechanics there is also
strategy to consider like whether it's
your first or second serve where your
opponent is standing and what your last
serve was like just like in baseball
where pitchers want to avoid throwing
the same pitch over and over servers
like to mix things up keeping their
opponents on their toes one thing that
most sirs have in common at least that
the professional level is speed lots of
speed we're talking about serves that
leave the racket at 120 130 even 140
miles per hour and the absolute fastest
serves on record reach into the 150 but
is that as fast as we can go today we're
gonna look at why serving a tennis ball
160 miles per hour is almost impossible
to find out what it takes I talked to
one of the biggest servers in the game
mechanics are critical having good
mechanics having good flexibility allows
you to kind of have that leverage to
make the ball really move tested my form
with a sports scientist we don't want to
be going straight up we actually want to
be going in that direction there found
myself on the receiving end of some
pretty humbling serves and even
sacrificed a camera look at this that is
what 120 some odd mile per hour served
will do to your GoPro the game of tennis
has always had huge hitters in 1974 at a
speed competition held at the US Open
Australian Colin Dibley was clocked
crushing a tennis ball at 148 miles per
hour but that was it a competition
designed specifically for testing speed
in match play most players don't hit as
hard as they can because they also have
to control where the ball goes still
serve speeds have increased over the
years through the 80s and 90s the
fastest serves on record were in the
130s in the late 90s we saw the first
serves in the
40s and in the early 2000s we saw them
creep into the 150s
the first time the fastest serve ever
recorded that came in 2012 when
Australian Sam Groth was clocked serving
a tennis ball at 163 point seven miles
per hour
now the association of Tennis
Professionals does not recognize that
serve and that's because Groff delivered
it at what's called a challenger event
where the serve speed guns aren't
subject to the same standards as those
on official Tour events the fastest
serve recognized by the ATP that was
delivered by American John Isner at a
speed of 157 miles per hour so what does
it take to hit a serve that fast and
what's keeping them from getting faster
you want to jump a little towards where
you're serving that way you're the
momentum of your bodies kind of helping
you out with the power and all that
ulysses Blanche is a 21 year old Pro who
can hit serves up to a blistering 138
miles per hour we visited him at the
USTA national campus outside of Orlando
to learn some fundamentals so like
what's the first thing people learn when
they learn to serve you think throwing
the ball talking getting that consistent
yeah trying to get that as consistent as
possible yeah let's see if we can at
least clear the net this time get a
little higher if you can as you can see
my form was yeah but with Blanche's help
I was at least able to improve my serve
speed 77 but it didn't take long for
that pride to wear off so now Ulysses is
gonna try remember 77 miles per hour is
the speed to beat I'll keep that in mind
I'll try to do it he's casually hitting
triple digits in his warmup and if you
think hitting the ball that fast stuff
just try returning it look at it this
way for a 130 mile per hour sir you've
only got about half a second to react
first like a split second every single
time he serves it's like no I got it
it's going here and then I don't have it
at all okay so I definitely won't be
joining the ATP anytime soon but I'd at
least like to understand why my serve is
so much slower than Blanche's so what do
you think is keeping me from serving
fast
in 77 I mean its technique all that is
technique so here you are over on the
left and then this is Ulysses serve on
the right we recorded our session with
cameras from multiple angles and then
asked us ta performance analyst Dave
Ramos to compare our mechanics contact
quite a bit of difference from one to
the other huge difference the biggest
difference is how we store and release
energy it all starts in our legs
Blanche's are straight but mine are bent
that's because I'm using my lower body
to help throw the ball into the air
that's very common actually for new
servers to almost feel likely to have to
put some energy into the end of the toss
Ramos says your arm is more than strong
enough to lob the ball on its own and
involving your legs at this stage
actually just adds more complexity to
your movement which can make your ball
toss less consistent now look at our
hitting arms blanche activates his by
drawing it back in one fluid motion my
arm it barely moves at the point of
release our bodies could not look more
different look how open Blanche's chest
is by rotating his hips and his
shoulders he's already begun storing
energy in his upper body this is called
coiling and I am really really bad at it
just watch what happens in the next
stage of the serve by the time the ball
reaches its apex Blanche's upper body is
so tightly coiled his shoulders are
pointing at the sky mine are practically
level with the ground you'll also notice
that while we've both bent our knees to
store energy in our legs Blanche has
shifted his weight in a way that will
allow him to leap not just up but
forward towards the ball as he explodes
out of his squat this allows him to
transfer the power that he stored in his
leg upward through his body and into his
racket by uncoiling his hips his torso
and finally his shoulders right before
impact Blanche's arm is fully cocked and
the head of his racket is pointing right
at the ground the result of a huge
external rotation in his right shoulder
just look how high his elbow is relative
to his hand my external rotation by
comparison is basically non-existent
which brings us to the point of contact
you're basically looking for as close to
a straight line from the tip of the
racket down through the hand to the
elbow to the shoulder and then to the
hips and then out through the body so it
looks pretty much like a straight line
where you can see on yours you have a
couple of segments right no lines and
angles going on the good thing is you
are centering the ball which is pretty
good but the tip of the racket comes
down to the hand then the hand goes down
to the shoulder and then the rest of the
body is one sort of a straight line
those zigzaggy lines highlight breaks in
my kinetic chain the sequence of
rotations that some the force is
generated by my lower and upper body
okay the kinetic chain is crucial for a
high-powered serve a very efficient
kinetic chain energy transfer means that
whatever energy you can create from your
ground reaction forces nearly a hundred
percent of that gets shifted up through
the body out into the ball that's mark
Kovacs a sports scientist who works with
some of the hardest hitters in the world
we visited his lab outside of Atlanta
Georgia where he covered me in sensors
and had me serve on a pressure mat so we
could pick apart my serve one of the
first things we noticed was my lack of
force production even if my technique
had been perfect I just wasn't
generating that much force with my legs
your peak force here is between 800 and
900 Newtons which is pretty normal for a
recreational type player the pros are
50% more than that many of them up at
1500 some of them even a bit higher than
that plus not only was I generating less
force I was also putting that force in
the wrong place so you can see it looks
like a vertical jump right there yeah so
if we look at on the screen that would
be a standard looking vertical jump if I
was doing an NBA combine or NFL Combine
I'm actually reasonably happy with the
position there but on Antenna serve we
don't want to be going straight up we
actually want to be going in that
direction there and finally I wasn't
rotating my shoulders enough remember
it's all about that coil but you've got
what we call an inefficient kinematic
sequence you know it's all happening at
once so you're not getting that benefit
or that summation of forces that we'd
like to see and inefficient can
a chain transfer means that that hundred
percent of ground reaction force that
you've produced you may only get 70
percent or 60 percent of that into the
ball that's a very inefficient model and
that also potentially increases your
injury risk because you have to do more
in the upper body as you can see you
also collapse right at the end which
doesn't look very healthy there we've
bent over we're collapsing falling to
the side
I'm just keeping track of the adjectives
mark is used to describe my form we've
got weak inefficient and collapsing
again they're all fixable that's the
good thing there's plenty of opportunity
for improvement here and that's what we
like to say one thing I can't fix my
height it's pretty tennis player you're
not that tall so then that's a little
higher for you so you can't really hit
down on it and that makes a difference
Rylee up Elka is one of the fastest
servers on the tour he's also tied for
the tallest you know being seven-foot
helps the main difference is the
trajectory and the way the angle is
coming at is significantly higher so the
way the ball bounces off the court the
you know the peak height of it is
foreign to a lot of players they're not
used to seeing a seven footer you know
serving from from that height and the
ball coming from that angle
you've got to really look at some of
those tall players if you're looking at
the absolute you know fastest overs the
Johnnies news of the world Wilier pokers
they're all six seven and above you can
actually graph that correlation here's a
chart of some of the fastest serves on
record in relation to player height that
line visualizes the relationship between
player height and speed you don't need
to be tall to hit hard but it definitely
helps in a couple concrete ways you've
got longer levers so you can store
energy over a greater amount of time and
then it allows you to summate your
forces over a greater distance the
second big thing is you've got a height
advantage from a geometry standpoint six
foot seven is what's the estimated
height is for people that can actually
hit down on a serve anyone under about
six foot seven actually is still hitting
up on the surf so if you're hitting up
on the surf you're fighting gravity if
you're heading down on the serve gravity
actually helping you but height isn't
everything part of having a you know
developing a big service having good
coaching and good mechanics we've always
been on top of my flexibility through my
shoulder through my spine good mobility
it's all critical if I have a lot of
players that are mid six feet that have
very very fast says you know Andy
Roddick was an example six to is range
and it still has one of the fastest
service of all time so it's not a
one-to-one correlation but it is that
predicta it's one of those predictors
that the taller you are the higher the
ceiling you have to have a great and
faster if you have someone with pure
technique nearly a perfect technique
rich andy roddick does have and you add
height to it and the technique is
maintained then for sure you're just
going to increase serve speed from that
standpoint so that's where the argument
can be made that we do have sill a
higher ceiling for serve speed
potentially so what drove those steady
increases in serve speeds in the 80s 90s
and early 2000s and why aren't we seeing
them today a lot of it has to do with
technologies sort of being relatively
consistent over the last five years if
there is a technology change going
forward we could see a spike over the
decades it's the evolution of the
racquet that has probably had the single
biggest impact on surf speed for much of
the 20th century wooden rackets
dominated the game of tennis but in the
mid 70s manufacturers began
experimenting with materials like carbon
fiber and resin to produce rackets with
much bigger heads in the 1970s your
standard wooden racket had a surface
area of about 70 square inches but the
modern racket is well over a hundred and
that increase in size had two effects
number one it made the sweetspot bigger
which made the game a lot more
approachable for amateurs typically the
sweet spot is in the upper part of this
racket and it's maybe a little bit
bigger than the size of a ball and a
modern rackets it's quite a bit bigger
but on you know a racket like this if
you don't hit the racket dead center in
the middle of strings it's not going to
respond or it's going to be unstable but
professionals didn't really need a
larger sweet spot and for them bigger
rackets had a different effect the
ability to put more
spin on the ball that's because more
surface area means more room for the
ball to roll across the racket and
gather spin thanks to a phenomenon known
as the Magnus effect a ball hit with
more spin dives towards the court at a
sharper angle once it clears the neck
putting more spin on the ball allowed
pros to lower their risk of hitting out
of bounds when they hit harder the
result more powerful play and faster
serve especially for bigger stronger
players advances in strength technology
have also had an impact on serve speed
where players used to string racquets
with cow gut today's pros use some
combination of polyester strings that
can be made fat or thin round or square
shaped and strung at a variety of
tensions depending on the players needs
and style of play it's important to have
just the right tension because it gives
you the ability to create power without
a lot of effort so if you string higher
you're gonna have more control and
string lower you have more power in fact
a lot of players have several rackets to
choose from in a given match they'll use
one for serving one for returning and a
whole bunch of backup rackets for
anything that comes up while sitting
when the coach was preparing Serena
Williams rackets uses all 11 racquets in
a match because she has a tall abases
covered players are incredibly sensitive
to racket tension and conditions and a
lot of times it happens it changes us
the match goes on right if it gets more
humid or it rains or the balls change a
little bit they want to have a lot of
options the ball can affect serve speed
to new balls tend to fly faster than old
ones that's because balls lose pressure
over time and the more you play with it
the fluffier it gets which increases
drag environmental factors can also
impact your serve speed including
whether you're playing on a hard clay or
grass courts court surfers can play a
bit of a role even though it's being
measured in ball speed in through the
air
what quad speed does is it changes your
strategy if you've got a really slow
court you may not try to serve as hard
you may be more strategic so it changes
how people serve and then there is air
density which is affected by things like
altitude humidity the higher elevation
you're at and the more hot and humid the
air the less resistance the ball
experiences trains leading to faster
speeds conditions are everything
I guarantee you you won't you won't see
a guy come to the French Open on a slow
clay court in Europe when it tends to be
a little cooler out maybe rainy you
won't see a guy serve over 150 there but
we do see a serve you know peek over 160
I would think it happened somewhere on a
hot fast hard court somewhere like in
Atlanta or Washington DC so what have we
learned
number one if and when someone finally
does break into the 160s
officially they will almost definitely
be incredibly flexible in their hips
torso and shoulders and be able to
uncoil those elements in the precise way
necessary to translate power from their
legs through their body and into their
record they'll probably be swinging a
cutting-edge racket and hitting a
brand-new ball and odds are pretty
decent that they'll be playing on a hard
court in hot humid weather and they'll
probably beat all the point is no one
can say for sure when all of these
variables from form and fitness to
height and equipment will align or
whether they will at all but until they
do keep in mind that what the hardest
hitters in the world are doing today is
already almost impossible
[Music]